all right
who are these people
ah
yeah
they don't do that for Laura
will waiters earn less thanks to the IRS
the Internal Revenue Service under Joe
Biden now wants to crack down on tips in
the service industry
and that's why Jesse Waters never tips
to reduce his waiter's tax burden
under the service industry tip
compliance agreement or
bartenders waiters waitresses and
Busboys would have to report their cash
tips to their employers no one would be
safe not even the crew that waxes Bill
hemmers back
that's 12 guys
employers who opt into the program would
then have to give the IRS annual reports
which is a great way to motivate
employees to key your car
the IRS is asking for input from the
general public before they implement the
program which will allow the IRS to do
what they do best totally ignore you and
then bleed you till you dry first part
the IRS says this would actually
decrease taxpayer burdens the LIE being
if we take from these poor bastards we
might take less from you you poor
bastard but since when has that ever
happened when the IRS finds new Revenue
do they ever say oh you other guys are
off the hook no that's a lie
just like Janet yellen's hairstyle is
saying relax it'll grow out
[Laughter]
I guess it's just hard to trust a
government agency that wants to sick 87
000 new agents on you what say you Joe
no no no look look don't forget who
you're talking to this is Old Joe all
right I used to wait tables
I was the only white waiter in an
all-black restaurant
and there's some bad dudes in the
kitchen
yeah we had a line cook by the name of
greens
collard greens
I said to them collard greens you get me
that order of grits are you going to be
eating that spatula are you going for
lunch
I damn if I didn't get my grits
collard greens live to grill another day
[Applause]
nothing against screwing waitresses but
this screws them really bad
well I'm glad to know that
oh my God uh yeah remember when you know
the administration added all of those
new IRS agents and billions and billions
of dollars beefing up the IRS saying
they were gonna go after the super
wealthy who weren't paying their fair
share and I and many other people said
well what the IRS usually does is goes
after people who make less because they
have fewer resources to fight the IRS
they don't have you know who doesn't
have resources to fight the IRS a
waitress right so of course this is what
we're doing we call that what they're
doing we could have called call that
this is what they were going to do uh
it's it's absolutely horrible I mean it
worked as a waitress for a long time and
I wasn't good at it so like when I got
like a good tip I like needed to keep
all that right yeah
I'm just trying to imagine you being a
waitress it was so bad I spilled
something on someone and instead of
getting paper towels to help clean up
you know what I did I asked them are you
mad at me
please don't tell anyone like like
as if they care like we're gonna it's
gonna ruin our relationship we're
developing Julie do you ever work in the
service industry and I mean that in a
clean way well
uh well so that's a loaded question yes
those are good but I never got tips no
never but the service industry that I
worked in was like cool stuff like on a
Friday night I worked at a movie theater
with a hair net in my hair in a bun on
Friday night serving all my friends I
wonder why I was single from like age 16
through 35. but uh and then no so I
never got tips but I have to say I feel
very strongly about this because I'm a
big Tipper and I do believe in the
service industry being tipped because
first of all they don't get paid Jack
they pay minimum wage for most of them
today I was at a hair salon and she was
afraid for me to venmo me her tip or for
me to venmo her her tet because she says
now they're going to start cracking down
on our tips and that's what they live
off of they live off of their tips
because their hourly wages are so low
and that's why Tyrus this sounds so the
government sounds like a desperate
junkie going through the seat cushions
of a sofa they want they're like we've
run out of billionaires let's go after
the waitresses this is just what the
Democrats do we're for the people yeah
we'll hold the money
um they this is how you I'm gonna teach
y'all a little Hood way to deal with
this this is how you this is how we
would do it in the hood when you pay
your tip you write one dollar
and then you give them the dub Dub's a
20. I'm saying everybody when you marked
it down I know but you know it's my base
what we're gonna do uh
teachable moment but you everyone write
a dollar when they tip that's what
they'll claim on their taxes and they
keep the rest so you know kiss my ass
there you go how much did you make a
dollar
and I and they're not doing it
it's not their fault that my big dumb
self can't count I wrote one dollar and
I left twenty dollars oops Yeah so uh we
need to get that around and just spread
it around because it's they make what is
it on a really good restaurant it's like
four dollars an hour so yeah but yeah
you're gonna but here's the deal good
luck getting good service anyways
because they worked most of them worked
themselves to little death during the
pandemic so like when you go someplace
when someone is working hard it's it's
you just don't have good service on top
of that now you're going to get tipped
so get used to self-serve restaurants
yeah robots yeah automation yeah you're
gonna need all uh what was his name uh
grits to come bring you food or whatever
but yeah that's where we're gonna be at
you know uh and the way you talk I
imagine you were like a bartender you're
a bartender never we had bar back nope
dishwasher when I was a kid
abduct a woman
well does it count if it was another
country
I like tyrus's idea about that just
leaving a dollar yeah yeah but you just
like that part but don't actually leave
the dollar yeah
no but don't Jesse Waters it yeah I
could see Greg doing that you know and
then all of a sudden they put it you
know in the media online and he took his
friends out to a steakhouse three
thousand dollars and he left a dollar
Greg Gutfeld the number one guy in late
night leaves a dollar yeah for their
taxes he did it for them yes you know uh
then that they would go like first James
Corden and now me but uh I'm I think I'm
a decent Tipper you know I did very well
on delivery because I feel bad that they
have to come to my house yeah
if you're an IRS agent if you go out to
dinner now down at the story's out there
don't tell the waiter waitress what you
do for a living because your food's
coming back with spitting it ah